okay why don't we why don't we go ahead
and get started I want to welcome
everyone to our usual Thursday noon
research conference or 11:30 research
conference and I'm delighted to
introduce our speaker today I've over
the last month or two gotten to know
Steve Shea who is the director of what
old-timers of you and me would call the
crow it which actually now has a new
name the Oregon Institute of
Occupational Health Sciences and
actually Steve and I are part of this
group that is trying to build this
establish this collaboration with a
group in Thailand which as you may know
things are a little unsettled in in
Thailand but anyway some as we got to
know each other we thought it would be
useful to cross pollinate our respective
programs so actually you may have showed
up in a few emails I gave a talk
yesterday at their Institute and Steve
is gonna give a talk today and I'm
hoping I asked him to try to talk about
things that might be of interest as I've
gotten to know his work and sleep and
and safety and a lot of it generates
data I see a number of touch points and
so hopefully going forward we might
establish some collaborations so Steve
is currently senior scientist director
of the Oregon Institute for Occupational
Health Sciences he holds a PhD in
physiology
from the University of London and he's
actually been though in the United
States for a number of years our our we
were actually in the same city for a
brief period of time when I was
finishing my NLM fellowship in Boston
back in the late 80s although I
didn't know him then and then I came
here in 1990 in the meantime he was on
the faculty at Harvard Medical School up
through the rank of associate professor
and then then relocated here to had the
Institute formerly called Croat I always
think of it as CRO it but anyways so
he's going to talk to us today about the
activities of his Center and and the
interesting work that he does well
thanks very much bill and do you know
what grow it stands for yeah correct
yeah okay well that's one of the reasons
we had to change the neck I mean the a
lot of people in our group do do do
environmental and occupational
toxicology but it didn't really reflect
the whole breadth of what we do and I'm
gonna sort of put the my talk in two
parts one is to introduce the Institute
and and the and some of the activities
research activities in the Institute and
another is to talk about my own research
so it's an amazing fact that the state
of Oregon pays one sixteenth of one cent
for every hour that you will work to us
to to try and do to meet this mission to
conduct basic and applied research
outreach and education to address
Oregon's occupational health needs that
comes from a workers compensation fund
so we get a
instigates at just over three million
dollars a year to do that we have about
16 faculty and about about 50 or 60
people but we also bring in other funds
most most of our funds actually come
from NIH we have about a budget of about
8 or 9 million million dollars a year
and it's a very eclectic Center I would
say trying to get to understand what
they do the main research areas and I've
segregated into five or six areas one
is called total worker health and this
is Oregon healthy workforce center is
housed within our Institute it's one of
four centers of excellence across the
country funded by NIOSH and it develops
tests and disseminates programs that
integrate safety health and wellness to
reduce injuries and improve health so
the idea there is if you if you just
focus on safety you're ignoring health
and if you just focus on health you
ignore safety and the two play off each
other you can imagine that if somebody
concentrates on on the health they go
for a run every day they're not going to
really do too many unsafe practices at
work so they they help each other and
that's the total worker health motif and
they're just put in a competitive
renewal for that grant Kent anger is the
director of that Center it's a great
Center it really I think really does
reflect overall what what our mission is
just along that along the lines of crow
it you know the old crow occupational
toxicology so here we the exposure
component you have workers who are
exposed to chemicals pesticides etc and
this group characterizes the effects of
occupational exposures determines
mechanisms and develops interventions to
reduce exposures and adverse
consequences and I should mention that
we don't only work in Oregon to complete
this mission as I said a lot of the
money comes from the NIH we even have
what one faculty member who's hardly
ever here is mostly in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and he goes around
there with the bodyguard doing his
research looking at people who who have
under processed cassava roots and they
they have to eat these because they're
hungry but they don't process them well
enough and they get cyanide poisoning
which affects the nervous system and he
you know he does genomics all the way
through to interventions in the
community and education to try and
prevent and help help those people
another group looks at strategies and
solutions for
mobile workers so here for instance we
have young workers aggregate
agricultural workers many of them
migrants solitary workers who don't have
the community ethic they don't have a
wellness program at work you know things
like that and an example here is
somebody working on the summit summer
interns that come and look after the
life you know the Life Guards of the
swimming pools over the summer who you
know young people they don't think they
were ever in danger and they'll do
things which are more risky and so
that's a education and intervention
program in that group and going back and
the solitary workers truckers isn't it
is another group that we look at so
injury treatment recovery and prevention
we we have a small group of people who
are looking at you know regeneration
after it's for instance a laugh a
laceration injury and an affiliate
faculty member who looks at pain
medication and opiate use and and trying
to see if that is abused appropriately
the cross or again there are a lot of
deaths related to opiate use and this is
one of the problems of workplace
injuries or any injuries is the chronic
use of of pain medication and then what
I really came over to start up with or
grow anyway is the relationship of
workers health to sleep and shift work
so my research background is in sleep
sleep disorders and circadian rhythms
and as that relates to shift work so
what we're trying to do is build a
program that will screen and treat sleep
disorders in the workforce educate
workforces about sleep health I'll talk
a bit more about that to improve sleep
safety and productivity and overall
health and along that theme so if you
think we I think of this theme is sort
of a vertical theme going for molecular
and cellular research through animal lab
research I don't know if you can read
that the back but then it goes human lab
research workplace interventions
education disseminate
and outreach and we have in the sleep
thing we actually have some people you
probably already know one person is in
this realm is Chuck Allen he's looking
at how the circadian pacemaker works
looking at the neurophysiology within
cells and within the network of cells
how they communicate and how they send
signals to the rest of the body to
organize our physiology and our
behaviors
he's been here for many I would imagine
like at least 15 years somebody who just
arrived last year from Harvard is
Matthew Butler a new new faculty member
he's not looking at the cells but he's
looking at the organs
he's looking at sort of shift work in
animal models so in mice and then I'm
looking at ship working and sleep issues
in humans in the lab and I'll show you a
picture of the of the new labs we've
built here in that field in the Hatfield
building and then there are a number of
people in our group who are looking at
workplace interventions we got that
involves sleep out in the workforce so
organizing organizational factors that
improve sleep health and safety of
performance some people that work on
that Ryan Olson and and Jacki Shannon
and and Carey Kiel who is affiliated
with our Center and then our outreach
group does a lot of Education on sleep
and shift work we'll always get asked
what's the best shift to do for my
workers to improve productivity and
sometimes they're interested in
improving health as well and and we also
have outreach I mentioned Jackie Shannon
earlier but let's get healthy as a
program that that she runs and I'm going
to talk to you a little bit about the
details of that in a few minutes because
that is that is yielding tons and tons
of data that might be amenable to an
informatics approach so I'll just
highlight a couple of a couple of
projects one is Ryan Olson he's doing a
really great work in in the trucking
industry so this is that long worker
issue and new truckers when they first
take out that job they put on about 30
pounds in the first year and
it's tough to get that off because of
the sedentary nature of the work and the
availability foods in trucks truck stops
etc but so Ryan has developed a wellness
and safety intervention program for
truckers it's it has training on dietary
choices self-management and he actually
has a team competition and that's
proving very fruitful because what he's
found is over the first six months they
people lost eight pounds that doesn't
seem like a lot compared to the 30
pounds they may have put on in the first
year but losing eight pounds over
six-month is amazing but what is more
amazing is that they actually continue
to lose weight with this month with this
program so it's not this yo-yo dieting
fad it's he got them to lose 18 pounds
over 30 months and now that's a man
actually I funded a project where he's
he's trying to do this in 400 the
trucker's he's nearly completed that
over a number of years so and and I
believe he's finding quite some more
results so it's a sort of competition
based wellness and health program and
going back he also found that that there
were reductions with this improvement in
health there were reductions in hard
breaking events in those truckers so
that they they were susceptible to less
danger and I imagine that that's likely
related to reduction in weight reducing
the amount of sleep apnea that the
drivers have and therefore improving
sleep and therefore improving the
vigilance but he doesn't have data on
that yet so one of the Centers as I
mentioned was called the Oregon healthy
workforce center and I would say this is
our flagship Center it has currently
five projects that they're funding one
is creating health and safety
communities for home care workers so
home care workers again they're usually
solitary workers but they're here
they're getting together and having sort
of group sessions on wellness and and
safety that's again with Ryan Olson as
the lead a team-based work life and
safety for construction workers but led
by Leslie hammer
the State University carry keel here at
sports medicine is doing health
promotion to reduce health risks in
correctional officers the life
expectancy of a correctional officer is
only about 56 years so if some of us in
this room were corrections officers we
might be dead by now and there's clearly
a lot of room for improvement in those
individuals of course if you're looking
after inmates you know 200 inmates all
of what they want to escape or do you in
it's a stressful stressful job that's
not it this isn't a study of the inmates
themselves who were probably undergoing
even more stress but I don't know what
the life expectancy of the inmates is
but but he's doing some great work in
those correctional officers I mentioned
earlier the health protection in young
workers those are the swimming-pool
black guards and then training the
supervisors to promote health and safety
in construction so here this is the
construction workers themselves and Ken
tango is doing a project on the training
the supervisors and there are other
pilot projects and outreach program in
that in that Center so but back to
another program that that studied that
grow it is let's get healthy with Jackie
Shannon and her mission is to partner
with communities and researchers to test
behavioral and lifestyle interventions
that are proving health to empower
people of all ages to make educated
healthy lifestyle choices and facilitate
population health research and disease
prevention so in this last aspect she's
collecting a lot of data her and Lisa
Marriott I don't know if you know her
but they they go to all these fairs
Community fairs they go to many schools
and some workplaces and collect data
this is what they do they put people get
a barcode wristband and they go from
station to station where they learn
about their diet their body composition
their blood chemistry some of them do
genetics very well a mouthwash for DNA
they have a sleep station and a cancer
cancer risk station you don't have to do
all of them if time permits you can do
all of them and the data gets collected
into a central database and your your
tagged your and ident
these tagged there is a possibility for
prospective studies I don't think many
prospective studies if that happened yet
but there is a cross-sectional database
which is being used by Oregon Health
Authority by schools and camaris
comparing school districts and health
issues across across school districts
for instance so that that's a really a
massive database I think they're you
know in there certainly the tens and
tens of thousands of individuals who
have provided all these kind of data
height weight body fat cholesterol
triglycerides glucose blood pressure
activity questionnaires sleeve quality
so there's a data set that would be
available of course it's somewhat biased
because it's it's not a random sample of
the population but is the vast at the
best sample and we also have one of the
biggest summer intern programs in the
university we have about 15 people per
year it's been going for I think 15 to
20 years since 1995 19 years right and
you know we we pay the students about
$3,000 a year we do the faculty member a
thousand dollars to help with that
project and the these summer interns or
undergrads really do learn a lot and
help our program to that's a valuable
program we also give numerous health and
safety seminars is an example you know
workplace aggression causes consequences
and prevention green chemistry safe
alternatives for work last year we we
did one on sleep sleep and shift work
impact on health safety and productivity
and then next week we have one on the
seven teri lifestyle so everybody sits
down much more than they used to
we have people who were going to talk
about do you need a standing desk should
you have a walking treadmill desk should
you move around so I should be moving
around as I talk now but so that's next
week it's on Thursday at the
what's that Pope Jane maximum mak
minimums Kennedy school next Thursday
you're all invited to come back I think
you have to register so look it up if
you're interested so now I want to talk
a little bit about my research on sleep
and occupational safety this this is an
old-fashioned pen probably and it says
moments later mister Higgy's fell asleep
and poke poke his eyes out so it's
obviously if if you're tired you were in
danger of peril at work but more and
more there's a recognition that it's not
only these accidents that are a problem
with locked loss of sleep it's actually
overall health so here's an it is a
cartoon that came out recently sleeping
occupation about Oh Wally I want you to
manage our elbonian contract programmers
you'll need to work at night because of
the time difference people who work at
night have more heart attacks are you
trying to kill me
yes and it's totally totally legal so
it's sort of a flippant look at some of
the actual problems that occur in in our
24-hour society and this is the
underpinnings of a biology of our daily
life come from the circadian system it's
a system that regulates all of our
physiology and our behavior it sort of
synchronizes the organs at at the right
time so that we're resting at night and
and active during the day and we're
optimally resting at night and optimally
active during the day and we can of
course at entrains in the environment
with jetlag you know you can you get
bright light and that will reset your
body clock but you know the problems
with shift work are that you get
fragmented sleep because you're trying
to sleep at a time when your body's
telling you to be awake and you have
increased accidents of course but
there's also these problems that we know
about which are associated with shift
work obesity diabetes cardiovascular
disease hypertension or some cancers
examples of well this is so just a
sagittal section through the brain
showing where this master clock is the
super charismatic nucleus in the
hypothalamus and the fact that it can be
reset by bright light so that you can
we readjust but it doesn't unfortunately
doesn't happen quickly it takes a number
of days if you go to come here to
England after shift by 8 hours it will
take you a week to do that or it could
take you two weeks if you could if you
reset the body clock the wrong way
instead of shifting by 8 hours if you if
you get the light at the wrong time
you'll start shifting the wrong way you
have to shift 16 hours it could take you
over two weeks to to do that you do
about now or a day so your vacation can
be messed up or your talks can be messed
up because of that we'd love a way of
shifting it quicker nothing's really
available at the moment so how do we
know that the suprachiasmatic nucleus is
the seat of the soul light this is a
study from 1990 but it's such a classic
that I really love showing it this is a
hamster who wakes up same time almost
every day here shown by running on a
wheel this activity here so this is
about two weeks of activity in this
hamster it's all done in dim light so
that hamsters not waking up because of
the light waking up because of its
internal body clock wakes up and runs
around and that's what's registered here
you can see this there's a slight
rightward right shift so it's getting
later and later each day the period is
close to 24 hours but a bit longer and
that's similar to humans our body clocks
slightly longer than 24 hours
if you lesion the suprachiasmatic
nucleus it becomes a rhythmic you can
see there's no pattern here but this
hamster has a mutation that makes it
have a shorter day length so here it's
waking up four hours earlier each day
it's about a 20 at 20 our internal body
clock and if you take care if you take
out the suprachiasmatic nucleus of this
animal and put it into this a rhythmic
animal you can make this a rhythmic
animal rhythmic but with the behavioral
check behavior of this animal so the
donor you're actually transplanting a
behavior by transplanting 20,000 neurons
from the suprachiasmatic nucleus into
this into the right place in this new in
this other animal so that that's a sort
of fascinating thing but just to
underpin the anatomy but now the
importance of it if his
here's our hamster actually these these
hamsters have got some vulnerabilities
this one's called a cardiomyopathy
hamster so it has something wrong with
this heart muscle so meaning it's
vulnerable it doesn't live as long but
here now this is this animal studied in
the light-dark cycle and and when it
gets dark that's when they wake up so
not only do you have your endogenous
circadian pacemaker but you also respond
to the light-dark cycle and so it wakes
up all the time as it gets dark and runs
on its wheel but if you just simply
shift the light dark cycle so here it's
like flying 12 hours you know flying to
Taiwan and back again every week which
is what Bill is going to be doing this
is what happens to the hamsters they
they do change their behaviors but they
die sooner we don't know why they die
soon and we don't know if people die
sooner because of if they do this kind
of thing but it just shows you that just
simply shifting the light-dark cycle can
cause these adverse problems and in
humans shift work or if this is a
massive study of 79,000 nurses and those
who report doing any shift work have an
increased risk about 20 20 percent
increased risk to 40% increased risk of
either fatal coronary heart disease
non-fatal MI or overall coronary heart
disease being about increased odds of
40% we don't know why so it is of course
shift work is also showing associated
with obesity and hypertension so these
might be the underlying factors cancer
is also increased so this is a number of
different studies which also which most
of them show an increased odds ratio in
those people who do shift work for
having breast cancer here and and cross
cam cancer prostate cancer here three
time odds ratio of three in this study
so there's a lot of interest you can
imagine that if you shift the body clock
then you become D synchronized in all of
your cells of operating at the wrong
time you
the metabolism every chemical reaction
in the body is occurring at the wrong
time it can have widespread effects on
all of our physiology and that seems to
be what's happening
similarly with diabetes in those people
who already have a fasting glucose which
is which is high they those who have
impaired fasting glucose have a five
times increase rate of developing
full-blown diabetes if they do ship work
so it's again this those people who are
on the edge of vulnerability then it
pushes them over this ship work and we
begun some studies so these are
epidemiological studies and I and what
really lacking is some evidence from the
lab there's some work in in animals and
what I've been doing is working humans
to see try and work out some of the
underpinnings of some of these changes
and an example that we do in the lab is
here we get volunteers to come in for 11
days
we put them in dim light they don't know
what time of day it is and we record
every breath they take every brainwave
every heartbeat their body temperature
every second we take blood every five
minutes - every hour we take their
saliva samples we take their urine
samples we do not take their fecal
samples somebody's asked for that and we
control their behavior so we tell them
when to go to sleep and we give them
specific meals and we allow them or
don't allow them to do certain behaviors
like exercise or whatever and and this
is some of the most intensive
physiological monitoring in humans the
volunteers of course getting paid under
standardized conditions with which
yields a ton of data and I'll show you
an even more intricate study in a minute
but this one what we what we did we
shifted when they slept so it's like
that hamster but we shifted them four
hours later each each night so the black
area is where people were allowed to
sleep in this protocol we also woke them
up
every three hours because we were
looking at lung lung function to see if
people had worse lung function join them
during the night hours for the body
clock or join sleep to understand its
nocturnal asthma but in addition we did
other things we we gave them
standardized meals here breakfast lunch
dinner and then a snack to simulate what
happens in real life and we were able
when people had their breakfast at the
normal time or when the people had their
breakfast in the middle of the night so
after they slept here they're going to
go into sleep about 2 p.m.
sleeping till midnight and then getting
up at midnight and having their
breakfast at sort of 1:00 in the morning
this is what happens here they're what
I'm calling a line this is normal food
and this is when misaligned and this is
what happens to their glucose all of
them or almost all of them increase
their postprandial glucose some of them
to the pre-diabetic level and one of
them to the diabetic level so if you
measured you know your fasting glucose
in somebody was a ship worker in the
mill and you took this sample in the
middle of the night you may you may
think that they've got diabetes whereas
they probably don't know all of these
were healthy individuals and this
increased glucose was not caused by
decreased insulin he was actually in the
face of an increased into it yep
what was that cortical steroid levels
what were their steroid levels I we have
the data but I haven't haven't got it
clotted on this kind of misalignment so
yeah we have cortisol melatonin
catecholamines so so I'm just giving you
a flavor of some of the work we do and
the potential availability of data that
exists so it's not your clinical
epidemiology this is the sort of
opposite where you have deep phenotyping
of mechanisms in healthy in healthy
humans
and excuse me this is this is an example
of a more intricate study I'll just take
a glass of water while you digest that
try and understand it so we were
interested in what happens in real life
to two people who have their body clocks
messed around and who have reduced sleep
because society is beset by the problem
of reduced sleep because of the 24 hours
so this is society by sleep disorders as
well and we also study two populations
younger people and older people because
we know that as people get older they
have less sleep so here this was I think
it was 37 days in the lab no visitors no
TV no internet no telephone no
newspapers no letters no light and
virtually no sleep we wouldn't we would
interact with them so the room is a sort
of is separated from the sort of
monitoring station by a double door so
we're going through the first door we
close it behind us to make sure what
light doesn't go into the subjects room
and then we go into the room and say
hello we don't say good morning or good
night because that we don't know what
time say good evening and and in this
experiment we gave people the black
areas of how much sleep they had so
before they came into the lab by the way
we we had them on activity monitors for
three weeks to make sure they were fully
aligned and replete with sleep so they
had ten hours sleep opportunity at home
every every day verified by telephone
calls to log that they came that they
went to bed at the right time and got up
at the right time and then when they
came in the lab we gave them 16 hours
sleep opportunity per day just to make
sure that had tons of sleeps that they
were not sleep-deprived because most of
us in this room probably obviously want
to get get rid of that so we gave you
the best shot and then we reduce the
amount of sleep available to them to 5.6
hours per 24
and when then we put them on a twenty
eight hour day so we shifted their body
clock every day by four hours as well so
this is a combined stimulus of of
reduced sleep and circadian misalignment
and the reduced sleep is accruing over
time so we get a really good stimulus
response over time so the sleep loss is
accruing over here and then we have a
recovery sleep here and lots of things
are being measured as I said every
brainwave you're looking at vigilance
looking at sleep debt and responses to
sleep loss when you're allowed to sleep
and we're looking at and I'm looking at
more of the physiology I'm looking at
the cardiovascular system and the
metabolic system and these yellow areas
here where we gave standardized meals
every in the in the morning and took
blood every every minute up to five
minutes to look at the glucose and
insulin responses and I'll just show you
one result so you know nothing like this
has been done before we also compared
young and old people so older people at
eight average age was about sixty and
young people was averages about twenty
five to see if there are differences
between people and you know in the lab
nobody's doing this at this degree of
sleep loss in in volunteers if you do it
there lots of experiments of sleep loss
in in animals and they've generally been
total sleep loss so like sleep
deprivation and those actually can cause
death of an animal after about twelve to
thirteen days this is just chronic
partial sleep loss which is what a lot
of us are exposed to and this was just
what we what we found for the glucose
for instance to the standardized meal
here this the young people on the left
and the older people in the right the
gray area is the response to this meal
here with glucose obviously increasing
and insulin increasing here and
similarly in the in the older people on
the right and then when we when they had
a history of this circadian misalignment
a sleep loss that the glucose response
is shown in yellow here
and the insulin response is shown in
yellow here so they have increased
glucose and decreased insulin this is
different from what I showed you with
that acute misalignment with just a few
days this is a few weeks and you get now
you get a different response with a
reduced insulin and still you get the
increased glucose which is considered a
bad thing yep yes
yeah well if the 90 minutes the is
talking like the cycle of non REM and
REM sleep it is approximately 90 minutes
it's not exactly an infinite ships and
we didn't you know cut down that by an
enemy it's we've just cut down by exact
proportion we tried to simulate what we
think is a strong stress in in
individuals five point six hours of
sleep opportunity for 24 hours was what
we went for it was what we thought was
the largest increase which was ethical
to impose for that amount of time so if
in that five point six hours that's the
only thing in our experience which we
couldn't control which is how much sleep
they had so the body's sort of going to
look after itself as much as it can it's
going to respond by having longer bouts
of deeper non REM sleep the more
slow-wave sleep and maybe more REM sleep
particularly certain circadian phases
that just happened and we documented it
and there's sort of dose-response curves
of sleep loss to this but it wasn't it's
not like you can just say cut off the
last cycle which probably did happen but
I think that those cycles may have
lengthened because the 90-minute cycle
probably lengthened a bit because of the
need for sleep increased and if you know
the need for non REM sleep would have
increased so in some circadian phases
you get a lot of slow wave activity I've
done a studying somewhere we were sleep
with obstructive sleep apnea and treated
them with nasal CPAP and instead of the
90-minute cycle of non REM Ram because
they hadn't had understood REM sleep for
many years probably
they went into a three hour period of
REM sleep
uninterrupted REM sleep but this is when
you're having vivid dreams etc if I
could have met you can only imagine what
they were dreaming about but three three
hours consolidator sleep and that's
because the sleep loss has was so great
the history of it that accrued and that
was the rebound so that 90-minute cycle
is a general rule but it's it can be
overcome by other needs so so this was
quite impressive finding we thought and
similar in younger and older people
which was a bit of a surprise surprise
to us and now we're looking at the
cardiovascular responses to to this
combined stimulus so again we have tons
and tons of data I can't analyze it all
and actually this was collecting Boston
before I came out here so I'm sort of
commuting via Skype etc to to try and
try and get all this data done analyzed
so if anyone's interested in this kind
of data set then it may be maybe a
variable so so that was all about
circadian misalignment if you if you're
doing something at the wrong body time
but going back to epicly this was really
what got me into the circadian field I
became very interested in wider heart
attacks and strokes occur on a with a
certain pattern across the day in the
night so here's two days actually the
date on the right are the same as the
data on the left it's just to show you
the rhythmicity a bit better and this
this box area is when we normally sleep
you see stroke occurs much more
frequently in the early morning here
about 9:00 in the morning and so does
myocardial infarction this so this also
has a daily pattern with a secondary
peak here in the early evening but fewer
events in the late afternoon and join
the usual sleep period of course people
are not stressing themselves so much
joints during sleep except perhaps those
with sleep apnea and that might explain
why there's fewer Mis and and actually
fewer reported strokes but you know what
there's also clear triggers to some of
these events so getting up in the
morning changing your posture increasing
your activity is taking a coffee and
getting into traffic being stressed out
all of these could induce you know and
that well they could induce the normal
physiological response which would be an
increase in sympathetic activity but in
some people that's gonna be some people
who are vulnerable
are gonna be at more danger for those
same normal physiological responses so I
wanted to also study whether there's an
underlying circadian component to this
there's some of some of this endogenous
because if it's just the trigger is if
it's just what people are doing then the
therapy would be could be very different
than if it's the timing of the body
clock that's causing this or it could be
an interaction so what what I the sort
of concept is that you have this
individual susceptibility and that can
potentially lead to an adverse event
caused by a behavioral trigger in this
individual person but also there may be
an interaction with circadian phase so
that that's what I wanted to study was
this sort of interaction an example
would of that is if you exercise at one
time a day do you get the same response
physiological responses a different time
of day is there a dangerous time to
exercise so again we we did it in the
lab where we can control the light dim
light we scheduled all behaviors and
this is you won't be able to see this
very well and I'm going to blow it up
and still you won't be able to see it
very well but this is the Hatfield ten
labs that just opened this month it's a
combined epilepsy long-term monitoring
EEG unit plus clinical research so it's
part of the oaktree clinical research
center now and three of the bedrooms
these three here which have blown up
here have been specially designed so we
can do light control and for our studies
so this is an example of a study that we
we did to look at the cardiovascular
responses to exercise so here's somebody
on a treadmill we've got them to
exercise here where the red bar is the
yellow dot is the core body temperature
minimum it's a marker of the circadian
phase of the body clock so usually
happens about 5:00 in the morning it
gets a bit later each day just like that
Amster that was running on the wheel a
little bit later each day our body
clocks is slightly longer than 24 hours
so about twenty four point two hours the
body temperature just sort of marched
along each day we adjusted when people
slept and when people exercised
again it was in dim light so that body
clock ticks away this phony inherent
rate this this yellow dot tracks the
body temperature minimum or the
circadian phase and by the end of the
experiment we have exercise shown in
this red bar at all circadian phases and
we can plot the data according to
circadian phase and this is what we find
so this is we're taking blood and we're
taking it before during and after
exercise and it the black line is before
exercise and the red line is during
exercise and we've plotted the data now
for the group according to the circadian
phase and we've double plotted it so
just to show the rhythmicity so the
light the data on the left are the same
as the data on the right and it's and
it's all basically we find out what the
circadian phase is from the core body
temperature and we and we plot the
response here so what you see is
epinephrine in your blood goes up during
the daytime and down during the
nighttime so the gray area is the usual
time of sleep but people are not
sleeping during these studies so that's
you know of course across the night time
we thought the biological night time
according to the body clock and this
curly braket is the vulnerable period
when heart attacks occur now this was
done in healthy people I'm trying to
really find out if there's any marker
that increases during this runnable
period that could be responsible it
could be caused by the circadian system
or interacting with the behavior and the
system that might be a trigger for these
events and and so baseline epinephrine
goes up and down so epinephrine is
lowest join the body clock night time
when body temperatures minimum and then
of course if you look at this point here
exercise increases that this is rest and
exercise so exercise increases
epinephrine no surprise there but the
increase in epinephrine actually is
double compare it's double here in this
vulnerable period compared to this the
night time so even though the red and
the black line looks somewhat parallel
in actual fact if you look at the change
in F in F
from here to here it's twice the size of
the change from here to here so that's
an example of something that is a
vulnerable a potential it's a it's an
interaction between the circadian system
of the behavioral system so that
exercise causes a different response in
the night time compared it to the
daytime you know that has implications
for shift workers but it might have
implications for when heart attacks
occur so if you have a much more
increased circulating epinephrine then
you might get a much more robust
sympathetic discharge and in response
and invulnerable people this may have a
an impact on their on the pathology so
that's the type of studies we do we
don't normally look at epinephrine we
look at norepinephrine and cortisol and
we look at parasympathetic activity from
heart rate variability data and of note
at the same time of vulnerability this
is when you get the greatest withdrawal
of parasympathetic activity when you
exercise so not only you're getting the
greatest change in sympathetic you're
getting the greatest change in
parasympathetic so it's this balance
between the sympathetic and
parasympathetic system the sympathize a
gold balance is greatly affected in that
vulnerable period it might be it might
be important and so we looked at many
other blood factors we looked at
platelet activation this is the
vulnerable period now shown in red we
saw cortisol peaking then we shorts or
platelet activation peaking then we
should we saw a fibrin oolitic inhibitor
with also peaking just before the
vulnerable period so these are blood
clotting or anti fibrinolytic factors
these two which might predispose to a
blood clot formation of Columbus and a
mi in runnable people at that time we
saw sympathetic the rate of change of
sympathetic activity during exercise was
highest and the rate of change of heart
rate was highest but the peak
sympathetic activity occurred later than
this in this Wonderwall period and
surprising we found blood pressure to be
actually the lowest in this vulnerable
period this is opposites what
we predicted and this is showing the
greatest change in parasympathetic
nervous system activity so it's more
than one variable that's going to cause
your heart attack we're not exactly sure
what it is this is healthy people we
studied but I just wanted to show you
the kind of data that we've been
collecting and I will be continuing to
collect in the new new labs that have
opened up here coming coming up I
thought I'd show you one one one more
example of a very very interesting
finding from a similar study so not only
did we look at exercise we we want it to
look at postural change because an
postural change could be just standing
up from from there from the bed but we
wanted to do it in a standardized way so
instead of standing up we put them on a
tilt table and we increased their their
height and we looked at their physical
responses to changes in posture and some
of them faint it all began to faint and
this is somebody of course at the
British changing of the guards in front
of Buckingham Palace who fainted partly
because they're standing there in this
heavy uniform with it and they cut that
you have to if you if you don't move you
you don't have the increase in venous
return if you have to like contract your
muscles in your legs that pump the blood
back up to the heart if you don't do
that enough and they're trained to do
that by the way now to sort of move
imperceptibly to then then you could
faint and if it happens during the
rehearsal for the for the trooping of
the color guess what happened on the
tripping of the color there yes and it
doesn't only happen in England this was
the Queen's birthday in 2010 but it
doesn't only happen in England it also
happens in Denmark but the common theme
as you see is the hats right so we know
why they have those very hats now this
because of this to protect themselves
when they fall over but so this was the
tilt table test and if you look at blood
the teal shaded areas when we tilted
them up to sixty degrees and this is
where we tilted them down and this is
blood pressure beat by beat you see for
about two three minutes relatively
stable about 120 beats millimeters of
mercury and it's stay it's remained
stable during the tilt up and then but
unfortunately for this person it just
plummeted here just went way down and
heart rate went down as well the
response to a decrease in blood pressure
should be an increase in heart rate but
their decompensating they decrease their
heart rate with a decrease in blood
pressure and that's when you get a dry
mouth you say mmm I don't feel so well
about to faint and we're monitoring the
blood pressure so we're gonna tilt the
table down anyway but this we looking at
symptoms as well so we tilted it down we
also look at codec output that went down
stroke volume went down so we tilt them
down so but the interesting thing was
these were people healthy people who
didn't have any autonomic problems and
this was happening in half the people
not all of them but half the people but
when it happened was quite striking it
only happened during the biological
night so most people are not exposed to
posture you know tilt table test in the
middle of the night probably were the
only people who's ever done it and we've
we think we've uncovered a vulnerability
in people who do stand up during the
middle of the night elderly people who
are at the insomnia they're susceptible
to Falls that's acceptable to to
fainting and and it might be that we
we've uncovered this danger that
possibly one of the reasons but it but
that's the that's just to me it shows
the real importance of the circadian
system or not not necessarily the
importance but the potential effect of
the circadian system on our physiology
and not only does it affect myocardial
infarction with as a alluded to earlier
asthma symptoms occur more nighttime so
we've studied you know whether nocturnal
asthma occurs at nighttime is it because
people are sleep at night is it because
they're lying down at night is it
because they're exposed
dust mites in their bedding at night
that increased allergens and and or is
it because of the body clock time so
with these intricate protocols we can
separate those out and that's similar we
did Studies on on epilepsy I'll just
show you the asthma data here we found
that in when we when we had people with
asthma in the lab they had a nice robust
circadian rhythm in in pulmonary
function and Airways resistance with
worse resistance or highest resistance
of the Airways join the usual sleep
period caused by the circadian system
not by sleep there's a separate effect
of sleep so they add up if you're
sleeping at night in a spa you're going
to get an increase in resistance because
you're asleep and you're going to get an
increase in resistance because your body
clock is it is asleep is it's the night
for the body clock those two add up and
cause worse than a spur at night time
and lo and behold if you look at when
the patients with aspects take their
medications when win this what the
window it's the lab situation they don't
know what time of day it is but they do
take their medications much more
frequently during the night time than
during the daytime even though they
don't know when the nighttime and the
daytime is so there this shows the
clinical importance of the of the
circadian system so in some way I showed
you that endogenous secatur with rhythms
occur in all organs tissue well I didn't
talk about tissues and cells but they do
I showed that this circadian disruption
affects health and that some diseases
are affected by circadian rhythms
themselves an example would be worse
asthma at night and possibly cardiac
events although we haven't studied that
in in a patient group and most of the
work was done at the Brigham Women's
Hospital in Boston and actually this
photograph was taken when I was
receiving a mentoring award so this is
my wife Elizabeth this is my PhD
supervisor who was a visiting from
London and he died a month ago ape Gus
is a great guy and we've just been
writing
all of the sort of obituaries to the
general physiology in London it's bring
him back all of his mentor's of sending
in stories of him what a great guy but
these are the the main people that
worked on this on this bug its Frank
Shearer he's now running the unit I used
to run in the London [ __ ] who is
visiting next week he he may be of
interest to some of you because all of
the activity monitoring that was done
and all of the heartbeat monitoring that
was done in all of these experiments are
being analyzed by him so he is sort of
our bioinformatics guy in Boston and he
I've invited him out to give a talk on
Friday that thinks June the 13th so I'll
send that to Bill and he could circulate
it because he he looks at the sort of
self-similarity of the data he's looking
at fractal patterns of activity rhythms
and finding quite astonishing things
about how our activity is regulated over
short times is very similar to how much
with accurate control over much longer
periods and some of that is related to
circadian rhythmicity there's no only
activity looks that but also hot
heartrate and he has data sets in out
slightly he has huge data sets in people
with Alzheimer's and activity and with
interventions such as light so I think
that his sort of mathematical approach
might be of interest to you all so
that's Kuhn who and I'll send that well
so I one thing that I think about you
know whenever you do you know
experiments in controlled settings is
whether anything you do
that's like abnormal like locking people
in the room for 11 days or something
like that has any possible you know
confounding effects on your measurements
or things like that I don't even know if
there's any way to test that but do you
ever think about that or no I we do
think about it then we ignore it no it's
it's you've hit a slight problem with
our studies and that is we generally
don't have a control group that doesn't
do anything they would stay in the lab
for 37 days and we don't do anything so
we try and get around that and say look
we're we're looking at the same people
well the only thing we're changing is
when we do things so and then we plot
everything according to circadian phase
but the way we can sort of look at that
is if we look at the the first week in
the second week in the third week and
whenever we've looked at the the overall
first week in the overall second week
and over third week they're the same so
there's nothing that is changing because
of the environment that that is
different across those weeks and we so
we think that the environment itself
doesn't impose a new you know a new
stress but we do we include in most of
our analyses a factor called you know
time into study so we have circadian
phase as a factor we have time into the
day length as a factor and we have day
into the study as a factor so that would
sort of control for any linear changes
across time you know there may be
changes immediately come in because diet
changes you know people what they have
saltier diets at home and when they come
into the lab there's less salt so with
less salt they lose a bit of weight
water they lose a bit of fluids but that
happens over two days and then then it
stabilizes so we don't always have great
controls but the latest program project
grant that they have a at Boston does
have a control group where nothing
happens and and that will be interesting
yeah
you need someone watch him all the time
are people likely to just kind of nod
off in the middle of this yeah
proportions where they're supposed to be
yeah so we have people there on camera
the whole time and it's not recorded and
we turn the cameras off when they go to
the back because they also have to you
know urinate into a bottle and well
there is a bathroom in there but so we
they're what they're watched all the
time for what's called a constant
routine protocol another way of looking
at circadian rhythms is to put someone
in a bed not let them move or sleep and
just look at their physiology change
over 24 hour period and then then we
have we actually have that people in the
room with them all the time you know
talking to them playing chess or drats
not so much poking but particularly
that's important for my cardiovascular
responses you know but one interesting
observation is the older people you know
the people that we have doing that as
sort of interns and young interns from
the unit local university and they are
also susceptible to fall asleep and it
turns out that they're more susceptible
to fall asleep than the oldest
participants who and sometimes you get
the participant waking up the
technicians is the OHSU Sleep Lab down
at the residence and in the waterfront
does that part of your group no no we
interact we go to seminars together and
we need to increase that interaction
because for there our overall
occupational health center you know
diagnosing sleep disorders in the
workplace is something that I want I
want to do but they're a separate group
okay thanks
you